ça y est c'est parti ne l'appelez plus
festival de saint chartier mais le sang
continue
une rencontre internationale de plus de
138 kg et dont 30 % d'européens
le festival du château d'ars repart pour
sa deuxième édition
on a le soutien des collectivités qui
nous aident financièrement humainement
techniquement et on peut compter sur eux
on a de très bonnes relations avec eux
c'est ce qui nous permet entre autres de
maintenir cet événement et en parallèle
de ça nous avons 180 bénévoles qui sont
présents sur le festival
avant donc le festival pour tout le
montage pendant l'exploitation et pour
le démontage qui nous permette
d'accomplir plein plein de tâches
bénévolement quatre jours avec des
concerts des master class des danses
trad valses mazurkas bourrées ad'autant
ou à trois temps un lieu des changes
en fait c'est un musicien qui joue du
bach que c'est un professionnel qui m'a
demandé ça en fait l'an dernier et comme
j'en ai jamais fait je lui dit je te
fais d'abord à la sono miroir tu viens
d'essayer il va l'emmener 13 d'accord il
part avec avec elle pendant un mois il a
joui me fais ces critiques et moi je lui
en fais une conséquence record étant de
la châtre étant enfant du festival de
saint chartier
quand ça s'est écrasé il y avait plus
qu'une chose à faire c'est essayer de
remonter
donc si ça le but c'était d'essayer de
remonter ça ne marche pas ça marche pas
mais les provençaux
ça fonctionne avec des concours de
vienne et de cornemuse en gardant
l'esprit festif et chaleureux de
festivals d'entente
côté programmation cette année la
musique occitane et baroque sont à
l'honneur le son se terminera mardi soir
par un grand bal trad en attendant
l'année prochaine